bonsoir et oui effectivement on est donc
aux bords de l'eure et je suis en
compagnie de monsieur laurent lullier
qui était lui au patrimoine à la
valorisation du patrimoine
mais avant de commencer je vous propose
tout de suite un reportage sur chartres
en lumières
une balade au fil de leurs pour
découvrir la ville sous un autre regard
hélène une outrance porte on se laisse
guider par le courant et on découvre en
canoë kayak les 10 points un billet de
lumière dans une ambiance aquatique la
nuit révèle sa magie et les artistes de
chartres en lumières l'ont bien compris
les reflets de l'eau et les ondes nous
font découvrir les bords de l'eure sous
un nouveau regard
le fil conducteur de
des illuminations de la base il s'est
quand même leur c'est la rivière donc on
est on a des thèmes notamment derrière
nous on à la collégiale saint andré avec
un phare ça fait référence notamment à
au thème de l'eau donc c'est pour ça
qu'on n'ait ya des ponts des lavoirs des
tanneries et sa une sur charte c'est ce
qui met beaucoup de métiers autour de
l'eau toutes ces installations sont
l'oeuvre de scénographe d'artistes et
surtout de techniciens qui travaillent
de nuit de 22h30 à une heure du matin
ils font leur ronde et contrôlent depuis
cette salle des machines
on est là tous les jours il faut qu'on
on voit tous les jours comment sa
démarche que ces deux vieilles machines
un petit peu capricieuse donc on s'en
occupe
on s'en occupe gentiment et bien
vérifier que toutes les sorties vidéo
soit à leur place et
voilà donc on vient ici tous les jours
les techniques de projection sont
différentes d'un monument à l'autre et
24 sites sont illuminés le musée des
beaux-arts à conserver l'une des plus
vieilles machines de projection d'image
les principes c'est que c'est comme un
énorme appareil à diapos dont la lumière
est projeté sur une pellicule en fait
qui est large large comme ça donc en
argentique et du coup c'est vraiment du
travail comme de la peinture
et pour terminer notre balade la façade
est du palais épiscopal nous fait
voyager dans l'univers de méliès avec
lunar et on n'a pas pu s'empêcher de
rester jusqu'à l'extinction des lumières
donc voila vous ne pouvez me retrouver à
tout de suite avec monsieur laurent
l'huilerie élue en charge et la
valorisation du patrimoine
alors dites-nous pourquoi chartres en
lumières belle chartres en lumières
c'était déjà une mise en valeur du
patrimoine
déjà faudrait avoir un beau patrimoine
donc la ville de chartres on avait un
très beau et c'était surtout mettre en
valorisation du patrimoine grâce à la
lumière pour représenter un petit peu ce
qu'il veut et ce qu'il était et ce qu'il
va devenir
et puis aussi rappelé aux chartrains
qu'ils ont une ville qui est vraiment
belle alors cette valorisation elle
passe aussi par la création
combien d'artistes vous avez sollicité
comment s'est monté ce projet depuis
2003 alors depuis 2003 où tout est
pareil avec un artiste
aujourd'hui on a plus d'une quinzaine
d'artistes qui interviennent sur
chartres l'idée c'est aussi de faire des
choses qui soit un petit peu différente
tout en gardant l'esprit de chartres en
lumières qui a un vrai métier un vrai
musée pardon à ciel ouvert alors c'est
l'une des plus grandes manifestations en
france
étant donné qu'il n'y a quasiment pas de
vilains qui est qui est un de ces
installations de lumières et de sons
c'est unique
il y en a quelques-unes qui commencent à
s'y mettre mais on al'avantage d'avoir
commencé avant tout le monde
c'est même unique au monde parce qu'on
est les seuls à faire ça sur autant dit
et sur autant de jours aujourd'hui donc
chartres à une avance à nous de la
garder d'être compétent et puis être
inventif surtout alors une thématique
particulière sur celle qui est derrière
nous c'est on est sur leur caisse que
comment vous avez choisi cette
thématique
je dirais que pour nous c'était assez
facile à la faune la flore avec avec sur
les bords de l'eure donc on a vraiment
remis en avant cet espace un petit peu
aquatique et et végétales après
je vous dis c'est souvent lié à
l'histoire du patrimoine et ce qui
représente sur la cathédrale on a des
choses qui sont un petit peu différente
on pouvait pas mettre la faune et la
flore sur la cathédrale mais entendu
alors chartres à une seconde vie le soir
combien de visiteurs viennent pour voir
charte en lumière un petit peu difficile
à évaluer mais j'irai les comptages
qu'ont été fait c'est plus d'un million
un million deux parents qui viennent
pour la lumière ce qui est quand même
quelque chose d'assez important bon faut
savoir qu'on est sur 180 jours et c'est
tous les soirs aussi d'accord alors
écoutez merci beaucoup
il ya aussi des retombées économiques et
c'est extrêmement important si pour la
ville de chartres
merci infiniment je vous laisse du coup
on se retrouve demain pour les grottes
de foulon et à demain merci beaucoup
c'est la bonne soirée et à demain pour
une nouvelle page été